I don't do no I refuse to take no for an
answer so I want you to start to praise
yourself I want you to wake up in the
morning the first thing you go as I like
myself when there is a battle during
logic and emotion emotion
always always always wins the motivation
what's your top ten with believe nation
what's that belief nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a woman who went
from struggling with an eating disorder
for 20 years who becoming an aerobics
instructor and later a successful
hypnotherapist and psychotherapist and
the author of four best-selling books
she's Marissa Pierre and here's my take
on her top ten rules a success volume
two
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one don't take no for an answer
I don't do no I refuse to take no for an
answer so if I'm told no you know and I
told you can't have a baby or you'll
never be able to do that I don't I don't
let that in which I find very useful I
do let in criticism but only if it's
useful and so I'd say that's probably my
best attitudes I just won't take no for
an answer and I was studying won some
celebrities cuz a lot of them and I mean
I don't put myself in that category but
what I found out was that celebrities
don't take no for an answer they're very
interesting they simply refuse to do no
and if you say to them okay we're having
a party everyone's coming wearing white
those have been green because they want
to be a little bit different but they
don't see it as a handicap they see it
as an asset and it's a it's a great
thing to not take no for an answer
rule number two don't fear rejection you
know we used to live in walled cities
and and our strength came from numbers
we walk we were in a group and when
numbers we survived I can live in an
apartment you can have cats and dogs you
can have your grocery table you can
never see anyone and you could live till
you 110 but we still feel is feeling die
if you reject me no you won't you'll get
stronger but you know for women
especially if you went back 500 years
ago you're a hunter-gatherer and your
guy died out spearing a wild you beast
you would die who's gonna raise your
children who's gonna feed you so in our
evolutionary psychology we have this
fear I'll die if you don't like me and
we try to get over it by buying stuff
and going to the gym and having our hair
down or getting a nicer car or trying to
impress people and what you should do is
impress upon your mind look I know you
think I'm gonna die from rejection I'm
not actually it's gonna make me stronger
and if you can dialogue with your self
and go okay I just been dumped I feel a
bit sad it's not gonna kill me it
that was a starter relationship the next
one is going to be way better then it
does make you stronger rule number three
deal with criticism a third thing you
must do to really feel great about
yourself all that having to radiate
confidence that real inner confidence is
to learn not to let in destructive
criticism you can't stop people
criticized you cannot let it in using
years and years ago when I was getting
engaged my boyfriend my boss actually
said to me when I said I need some time
for gay marriage when oh my god your
boyfriend so good-looking how on earth
have you got him to marry you I remember
thinking wow that's a bit hardcore and I
could have said something like oh yeah I
have to handcuff him to the bed he's so
good-looking but you see that's letting
it in and having to come back but I
could have said how dare you say that to
me so I just said to her oh it's called
love you know we love each other and I
didn't let in because I thought wow
that's she must be really unhappy person
to do that but much much later so I was
a different boy then someone said to me
called your boyfriend is so unattractive
you could do so much better why are you
with him and I went that's what an
amazing guy he is because I've never
even seen that I just think he's
incredible and I my daughter said we
mummy he's really ugly I said yeah I
know and I love him so much which shows
what a great guy he must be because I
just think he's gorgeous and of course
my daughter then realised that this
couldn't go anywhere with that because I
didn't let it in and so if you can learn
not to let in destructive criticism that
too will change your life women before
praise yourself here's some things are
going to start doing today right now
that will build your self-esteem
superfast the number one thing is to
praise yourself there is nothing nothing
nothing that will build yourself esteem
like praise but your praise if you have
a Shoppers image that oh you look really
great in the outfit yeah it suits you
you must buy it they have an agenda if
your boss says you're amazing at your
job I need to give you work to do over
the weekend they haven't
gender someone dating you might have an
agenda and your mind knows that when you
say I'm great at my job I'm smart I'm
kind I'm nice people like me there is no
agenda unfortunately when you go I'm
rubbish at my job I'm boring I always
mess up and I have no friends your mind
lets that into because your mind doesn't
really care if what you say is right or
wrong good or bad healthy or unhealthy
let me prove that to you
I want you to put your hand in front of
your face like that I want you to close
your eyes I want you to imagine you have
a big fat juicy lemon and I want you to
breathe in that wonderful lemon smell
and just squeeze it a bit and feel that
wonderful lemon texture because nothing
quite smells like a lemon so still
really believing you have half a lemon
in your hand open your mouth
shove that lemon in there cram that half
a lemon into your mouth and start
chewing and sucking and biting and
swallowing the flesh keep sucking all
that lemon flesh into your mouth bite it
chew it suck out the juice and you will
notice what is happening is your body is
responding to a thought as if it's a
fact your body is responding to the
image and thought of eating a lemon as
if you are actually eating a lemon and
it's making a saliva because thoughts
are things and every thought you have
has a physical reaction in your body and
an emotional response too and you think
I don't have friends I can't talk to
people I can't take things back to a
store I can't ask for special treatment
I don't know how to talk to people then
your mind accepts that as a fact just
like the lemon but when you say oh I can
talk to anyone I'm an interesting person
I'm warm and friendly people like me and
I can make eye contact I'm good at my
job I can ask someone out on a date I
can tell the person I'm involved with
what I need your mind accepts that too
and someone recently said they keep a
lemon
their desk now and look at it every day
I'm sure they change every month because
that lemon reminds them every day that
they are responsible what they think and
feeling you know responsibilities that
word means an ability to respond so I
want you to start to praise yourself I
want you to wake up in the morning the
first thing you guys I like myself
number five be confident we like people
who say I've got something to offer the
world and it's very it's people are very
reassured by confidence you know all
scared that we're gonna come across as
arrogant but if you're on a fly and you
hit turbulence you want a confident
pilot if you're sick wouldn't you like
you're really covered a daughter got off
I'm the best doctor in New York I'm
gonna make you better I don't want to go
as well I don't want to brag you know
I'm sort of okay sometimes but you know
he's better than me we don't want our
kids teacher to go well I'm not the best
you know I have good days we want to go
I'm the best teacher and I'm gonna give
you back your kid in a year's time rate
radiating confidence and talent you know
we pay for that and yet we're so scared
of saying I've got a gift I've got a
skill this is what I'm good at
rule number six pack your brain people
think the brain is really complicated
it's not it's actually quite simple you
need to know three things about your
brain to always get what you want and
the first thing is your brain does
exactly what it thinks you want it to do
because it listens to everything you say
so when you say things like oh god you
know I got dumped it's so painful I
never want to go through that again
all your mind can pick up is you don't
want to be in a relationship again when
people have a miscarriage ago I could
never never go through that again I'd
rather die than go through that again
your mind is picking up oh right well
that's that's a statement that's
actually a command to me to make sure
you never go through miscarriage again
and that that's how you get unexplained
infertility which is something else I've
been working on a lot recently because
the mind listen story says we will go oh
I went on this fly I was gonna die and
do it look I'm never getting my place
plane lands I will never ever get on a
plane again and of course it lands they
go lose just turbulence but next time
they go to the airport of a massive
panic attack because your minds like
hang on a minute you said I never want
to fly again and so if you haven't got
what you want it's because you're giving
your mind very confusing messages your
minds number one job is to listen to
what you say to interact on it the
second job is to move you towards
pleasure and away from pain and it will
always always always do more to avoid
pain so let's imagine you've gone for an
interview you've done a public speech
thing like me and you've stood up you've
gone oh my god I'm never doing this
again and you'd have a terrible
presentation and one of my clients work
for Sony was saying that she had to
stand up just say to Sony this is a new
band from Camden and she stood up and
went this is a new band from and they're
called I couldn't do it it's a simplest
thing and my boss had to take over and I
was explaining to her that when you do
that go I don't want to do I don't want
to do this again your mind is now going
to make sure you don't do it again so
the next time you go to speak it will
give you a panic attack or make you ill
and if you say to yourself oh my god I'd
love a week off in bed or I'm dreading
next word and say your mind is so in
tune with you your week off in bed you
wake up with a flu any ones that they go
how cool am I
there's your week in bed you do want to
go to that speech I've woken you up with
diarrhea sand now you can't go that's
what the mind does when I was giving my
first ever presentation about my first
ever book I woke up with the most
excruciating mire never had one before I
thought wow I must have been saying to
myself some I don't want to do this
because I've got this migraine and I'll
actually when did it and I didn't have
the migraine until I stepped back off
the stage again and I realized that I've
kept was communicating very badly with
myself so you must never say nervous say
excited because your mind listen so
those three things are your mind does
what it really thinks you want to do if
you're very very specific as I want this
and this I want to be a great speaker I
want to deliver things I want to be
fantastic at sales I want to be able to
you lie and sell them things and come
across it's really authentic your mind
will understand and if you make those
pictures really good and pleasant you'll
move towards them rule number seven
leverage emotions when there is a battle
during logic and emotion emotion
always always always wins how many of
you have gone to a really high building
and enclosed building like the top story
of a hotel or the CN Tower in Toronto
and look down at all wow I feel really
scared my logic might know is that I'm
safe that the glass is that thick that I
can't fool but the emotion that's making
my stomach lurch is winning so when you
have a battle between emotion and logic
emotion always always always wins here's
something you all know we can all ring
our friend I'm going a bit bored a bit
lonely can I hang out on a bit bored
let's go to the movie you would never
ring someone you've just met and go I'm
bored and lonely will you come and hang
out the let's go to the movie because
the emotion that you might be rejected
will overrule a logic that says this
person may be the person for me so if
you're having a battle between yourself
here's a great one I know I shouldn't
eat cake that's the logic with the
emotion is oh the cake feels so good and
this creamy sugary stuff reminds me
being a baby when all my needs were met
by having creamy sugary stuff so in a
battle during emotion and logic logic
will never win emotion will always win
and you can make that win for you by
making it a better emotion so here's how
to do it here's an emotion I'm scared to
ask for a pay rise in case my boss
laughed me out of the office make it a
stronger emotion if I go to my boss and
show them what I've done
valuable I am that won't happen here is
an emotion I really want to ask that
person on a date I'm not good enough
change the emotion I'm wonderful I'm
amazing
what could I get from asking someone on
a date that says yes so much if they say
no I'm only exactly where I was before
except I've been brave I've done
something courageous I've taken action
even if it doesn't work out I've lost
nothing but I've gained courage so when
you are having a battle during logic an
emotion emotion always wins logic never
wins that's why you could stand on the
windowsill of your apartment if it was
on the ground floor but you would never
stand on the windows their same size if
it was a hundred stories up because the
emotion that you may for defeat the
logic that says I can do this when it's
a few feet off the ground why can't I do
it up here because emotion over rules
logic you can make your life phenomenal
extraordinary and wonderful by always
using emotion to defeat emotion rule
number eight stop judging yourself every
baby on the world is one loaded with
self-esteem no baby when they're being
pushed down the street in their stroller
goes oh don't look at me of having a bad
hair day or I've just been sick on my
little romper suit or I've got really
fat legs baby's first exponents on the
planet is being looked at when you're
born the doctor the nurse the Midwife
look at you family come to visit you you
get your picture taken people show you
often babies don't avert their eyes when
you take their picture when Iced to push
my little girl down the street look in
her pram go my god she's so gorgeous you
never looked away she kicked a little
legs
she gave a big gummy smile cuz she knew
that she was gorgeous too and if you
ever doubt the children like attention
go to a park go to suing for new hair
every choking mummy mummy look at me on
the swing daddy watch me on the slide
mummy mummy watch me jump in the water
watch me swim watch me jump because
children have this bowl
if that I'm worthy of attention and I
like it and I can ask for it and I'll
get it and then you have to ask well
where does that go well it goes very
fast you know if I said I might have a
girl look - singing mummy a song she
would sing if I said to her 14 sing me a
song she'd roll her eyes and got my god
you're so embarrassing and walk out of
the room because at a very early age we
acquire a fear of being judged it's what
is called performance anxiety what if I
sing in someone laughs I mean what if I
read in class might get it wrong what if
I stand up to speak and I don't know
what to say performance anxiety gonna be
so intense it makes us stop performing
but people who perform really well like
themselves well I'll see what happens
and I'll sing or dance I'll act I mean
some people can't even dance at a party
in case everyone's looking at them and
judging them badly some of my clients
won't even go to yoga in case they can't
hold the poses like everyone else and
believe me we're all so busy worrying
about those we don't have time to look
at you and comment on your yoga position
or how you're dancing at a party and we
kind of like people who don't care who
just let go and have a good time so the
thing you need to have phenomenal
confidence really are two things stop
judging yourself and be nice to yourself
rule number nine do what you hate first
the very successful people if they have
to fire someone if they have to make a
very uncomfortable phone call they will
do it first and what's interesting is
that they naturally do that they would
say things like well you know I've got
to end a partnership with my best friend
or I've got to fire someone I really
care about
I couldn't possibly have that hanging
over my head all day I need to do it
first and then it's done and then I feel
better people who are not in that group
will go oh god I've got a fire like my
friend I'd do that at six o'clock I'll
wait till the end I do that after lunch
or I've got to go and do a grueling
workout I'd do that at five o'clock but
of course five o'clock comes and you
have a phone call to make or you've just
had lunch and then you don't get to do
it even in school and one of my clients
who is very successful said yeah when we
had to you know read out an essay I
never understood the kids who who went
last I put my hand up and went I'll read
the essay first because I want it done
so they do it naturally but that doesn't
matter because of course the wonderful
thing is that when you do what you hate
first enough times it starts to become
natural like I've got to do my taxes
I'll do that first thing I've got to
confront someone I'll do it first and so
I still to this day wake up and think oh
I don't really want to do that so I'm
going to do it first because what I do
want is to belong to that group of very
very successful people so I know what
the membership is and every time I don't
to do something I think I don't want to
do it but what I do want is to belong to
that group so I'm doing it first and
it's it's a great way of thinking
because it starts to move you around
wanting to do it for all the right
reasons and rule number 10 the last one
before a very special bonus clip is know
that you're enough I always say to all
my clients there's only three things
wrong with everyone
everyone has got three things wrong the
number one is I'm not enough the second
one is on different so I can't connect
and the third is I really want something
like freedom from depression or success
but it's not available but I'm not
enough is the biggest I mean I've worked
with hundreds of thousands of addicts
I've never found one ever that ever
believed they're enough and if we look
at the key addiction shopping binging on
food binging on alcohol binges drugs sex
sex especially porn all of those things
come from a feeling of emptiness inside
because we're taught oh you feel a
feeling what does she eat sand dune up
so go into eBay and buy or Amma's or buy
something or have a drink and our
feelings are the most real thing we have
and we push them down we found all this
stuff to buy or eat or
or take to keep us like John Lennon said
comfortably numb' but then the feelings
regroup and come back because they've
always got a job to do and I would say
to my clients look you've got to feel
the feeling until it no longer requires
to be felt you can't eat it or drink it
or shop it away but we're all taught
that we can and should so I'm not enough
is the biggest problem I see
now I've got a really special bonus gift
for Marisa on how to work on your
confidence that I think you're really
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three point landing question
it's time to move from just watching
another video to taking action in your
life or business and if you're feeling
bold leave your answers in the comments
below here we go question number one
where do you need to stop judging
yourself number two what do you hate
that you need to start your day with and
number three where have you been taking
no for an answer
people to have everything often don't
have the one thing they really need high
self-esteem it's why so many people who
make it and who we look at an envy like
Robert Downey jr. or Philip Seymour
Hoffman or Heath Ledger end up taking a
lot of drugs and destroying themselves
because they try so hard to make the
world like them and they succeed but you
have to like yourself so if you're
lacking confidence in any area of your
life that maybe in your career that you
you can't sell or you can't pitch you
can't speak or you're not very good at
going for an interview it may be that
you can't go for a promotion or in your
job you're not able to speak up and
share your ideas it may be in your
professional life that you're not
attracting the kind of person got to
share your life with because you don't
feel good enough maybe even in your area
of your health you don't go to the gym
because you don't feel you're good
enough to go to the gym you don't ask
for particular foods because you haven't
got the confidence to go out I don't eat
pizza or fries so whatever it is in your
life that you want when you work on your
confidence everything starts to fall
into place
if you want more marisapeter check out
the first top ten rules video I made on
her the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
successful people do what they hate to
get to where they want to be believe
without talent will take you far further
than Talent without belief